[Music]
hello everyone thank you for having me
and thank you for joining us today and
um today I will be uh focusing on a
little more on the surface part of the
so compaction and trying to give two
different studies that I had experience
before with the manure so Erin kind of
explained quite a bit about the
compaction and I'm just going to move
you guys a little bit more towards the
Manu applications and its effect on uh
compaction and um Rel some some related
so
properties so the first work I will be
presenting is going to be from South
Duda and and the second part of the work
second part second work is going to be
from the Wisconsin and the Wisconsin one
has sendy souls in the in the in the
field so there are going to be some
similarities to those areas in the east
coast but if have deep sendy soils and
hard pains in it in each cost then these
impacts of the manure on on the
compaction and other soil properties
could be could be more limited than what
it is in in this in this presentation so
three different things I want to
highlight here that I think they are
really important uh for manure
application and especially when we focus
on the soil property changes especially
from the physical
perspective would be the type of the
manure and handling an application and
also interaction with other uh
management practices like tillage or
field traffic uh because the distraction
factor from the disturbing disturbing
agents like tillage or or any other
field operations uh may be greater than
what we actually add as an organic met
and trying to expect positive
relationships with or positive effect on
soil compaction so poultry manure or
Hawk manure or or cattle manure they're
all having different characteristics but
within the cattle manure the beef manure
and da manure also has different
characteristics they have different
nutrient contents different moisture
levels that I kind of categorize them in
two different categories like nutrients
and also physically like moisture and
these are really important for manure
application and and expecting the
changes in so properties is because they
have different nutrient content and when
you apply the manure you calculate
according to nutrient contents like
nitrogen or phosphorus and they also
have different moisture levels so the
application amount of the manure is
going to be different in dairy or beef
so for instance here let's say we are
applying according to phosphorus or
nitrogen you can see greater numbers in
beef manure but when you look into
moisture you will have greater moisture
in Dairy means to reach the same level
of the nutrients that amount of the
manure you need to apply is going to be
much more in Daily and also because of
the moisture that's going to be even
more so just keeping those mind and
those in mind and pipe is really
important handling application is
important but then in the second study
we will be digging into uh some other
factors that is playing the critical
rule for those
changes so improper manure handling or
or or spraying or exercising of the
application can lead to so compaction so
it is important to consider the the how
much field traffic we are causing and
and so condition like we just me Aon
just mentioned about soil moisture is is
really important especially when you're
focusing on compaction and and also
application rates how much manure you
are adding there uh that that could be
even more concerning when you think
about the environmental perspective but
focusing on the compaction how are you
applying that manure are you applying
the solid manure on the surface are you
incorporating with the tillage or are
you just applying like in the picture
here on on the snow and in liquid form
or you're just Drilling in or injecting
in the liquid manure those are really
important factors to consider and
depending on the objective of of the
work so next I want to talk a little bit
about the manure management uh for
enhancing the soil resilience here we
have some different pictures of the
different size of the Aggregates and we
also have organic met playing critical
rule so there are different factors
there but I want to categorize in three
different category one is increasing the
sole organic matter and we know so
organic matter has an impact on the soul
structural development so the second one
is soul structure having a better
weather Soul structure usually help and
also the root growth having the living
roots in the system those are the three
different things that many could
incorporate like supporting more
vegetation growth or increasing the
organic matter and improving soil
structures so we have different
aggregate sizes and those has different
pores and particles together and and
also you can see even here in much
detail we have different pores in in
even smaller sizes and incorporating
manure in in the system can can lead
aggregation or increasing the organic
matter but at the same time we need we
need to consider that soil structure is
also playing a critical role there and
those pores are the where we store the
nutrients and those are the where we
store water and and we also need to
understand that organic met could be a
binding agent between particles and it
can also take place in in creating of
those pores so strategies to minimize
the compaction would be choosing the
appropriate equipment trying to avoid
the field traffic and also monitoring
the soil moisture level that's really
important and having the heavy
equipments in the field when it's moist
we just saw from the a in Stall that is
really really important timing and soil
conditions and and also uh incorporate
manure properly are you going to do a
reduced Dage just to incorporate the
manure are you going to spray it on it
or liquid form they're all really
important as I just mentioned in in the
previous slide too so the first study is
going to be about um different three
three different rate of the menu
replication rate and we have two
inorganic fertilized replication rate
and a control and for the manure PM is
representing the phosphorus based manure
application is a recommended rate for
satoda and NM is a nitrogen based manure
and hm means High manure which means
it's double rate of the NM basically so
this two two times nitrogen we are
adding in the system with the a then we
have nitrogen fertilizer where we add
nitrogen only for corn and then we have
high fertilizer where we support other
nutrients like phosphorus pottassium
zinc and sulfur as well and control
there's nothing no no manure no
inorganic fertilizer and we did this
study in two different sides which da
manure and beef manure are the one we
used for for each side and they were in
s theota and all my grass for this work
is going to be color coded so green is
going to representing manure and orange
is going to represent in organic
fertilizer and control is gray and
increasing the it of the color in each
uh in in figures they are going to be
representing the increasing the rate of
the menu replication so basically what
we have seen here focusing a little bit
on the surface 0 to 4 in that manure
application did decrease the B density
and increasing the rate also decreased
that and when we move into the second
depth is a subsurface 4 to 8 Ines we see
slightly changes in back density but
effect is limited compared to surface
dep means the impact of the menu is is
slowly moving in deeper profile but we
are still very close to surface so the
the another property that I'm going to
show uh soil structure really important
about the compaction and having more
aggregation having more pores in the
space is is really important we have
seen improvements in in Manu application
again increasing the rate has better so
for the surface manure has a great
impact on improving so structure in
subsurface it seems slowly moving and
this is the effect after 14 years both
bity and aggregate stability was 14
years of the application of manure and
we have seen some negative effect from
the fertilizer even though they are not
significantly different numbers were a
little low compared to control in
previous years this was not visible too
much but when we move forward to like
more 14 years level and we have start
seeing this more and more so impact of
the manure is is there in in aggregation
too so we talk about B density and soil
aggregation so of course they are all
related to pores and bigger pores
especially are going to be a good story
today we have in the second work too and
water infiltration is heavily depending
on that right so we have seen an
increase in water infiltration uh due to
the manure impacts and we don't see that
effect from the fertilizer
applications again don't forget the
color codes and looking into organic
matter comparing different years so
previously we were looking looking into
different deps right now in general we
are looking difference between between
the years so one year after we start we
have no seen seen no impact from the
manure in organic fertilizer and we come
when we come back after 14 years we we
we see a much more impacts from the
manure and it has been increasing the so
organic matter and increasing the rate
of manure application also increases all
organic matter
level so the next I'm going to show here
in this graph same thing with so organic
matter nitrate nitrogen also show
similar results you know the nutrients
can be responsive in shorter time than
the soil structure or other soil
properties we have seen a greater impact
with increasing the rate after 14 years
in organic fertilizer there were little
move but differences are not significant
and we have seen same trends for other
nutrients as well I'm not going to put
the figures for them here but just want
to sum highlight that other nutrients
were also showing the similar trends
that nitr nitrogen or or so organic
matter so the next is pH uh there's a
huge database behind this data this
slide so I just want to summarize here
for pH manure showed different reaction
in different fields the the pH show
different reactions to manure
application in different fields when the
pH level was high like 8 8.5 manure tend
to decrease that pH and when the level
of the pH was low about 5.56 level and
manure tend to increase that pH level
and but when we look into inorganic
fertilizer we know their pH level is low
so it's we always seen a negative effect
of the inorganic fertilizer no matter
whatever the level of the initial pH
is electrical conductivity probably one
of the negative effect of manure when we
apply in a really high rate this rate is
crazy like
17,700 pounds per acre that that's
that's too much and um and also we have
seen inorganic fertilizer has has either
no impact or decreasing and only highest
rate of the manure has increased
electrical conductivity but we are still
in the safe range right 78 is is a good
number for especially Souls like in s
Dakota has good structures and good
organic met levels uh I think the
numbers are okay
still so how about Biologicals uh and we
have seen support to fi and nitrogen and
carbon based enzymes like uas and metag
glucosidase and we haven't seen any
impact on bacteria because of the manure
application but fungi population and and
also some enzyme activities were were
increased again why we are talking about
all this properties together because
when we talk about the soil health and
which is focusing on soil compaction or
soil physical properties we have seen a
quite a bit correlation between soil
Health scores and crop yield in xais
here we we have the so Health scores
from left to right is increasing and
crop in the Y AIS from bottom to up is
increasing and you can see it's kind of
a not completely linear but very close
right so we have seen control right here
and then we have two inorganic
fertilizers and three manure so manure
is definitely helping the so Health
scores right but when we look at in the
crop yield fertilizer and low rate of
the manure has not not that much
significant differences uh but when we
look at so Health score fertilizer is
not significant like high fertilizer and
control they are not significantly
different so it seems the increasing of
the manure rate like you can see from
the lighter blue darker blue and green
like here we can see increase both from
the crop yield and so held as a summary
graph it's showing that high rate of
manure is also supporting crop yield as
well so that was the first study we
mainly focus on the different type of
Manu application and in here in second
study I want to highlight a little bit
about the disturbance factors with
manure or without manure so we had a no
till and conventional teal systems in in
Wisconsin and in on a slope and we had
the manure incorporation with solid
manure or or liquid manure and since we
first study was solid manure let's let's
focus on solid manure too so we can kind
of have some comparison there uh and we
also sample different times like before
tillage before planting after planting
summer before harvesting and after
harvesting so that way we can see the
impact of the Agricultural activities
right like planting Impact Summer impact
harvesting impact tillage impact with
and without the manure
scenarios so here the blues are going to
be tillage and intensity of the color is
going to be manure or no manure so as we
can see in the Box density we had a
greater box density in noal systems and
manure did not differentiate this was
very common in most of the so properties
in in Wisconsin in more
Souls uh we have seen greater impact
from the disturbance agents like tillage
or AG any agricultural activity that add
more traffic in the field or or erosion
sometime we had some some data to
measure that too so disturbing factors
due to the agricultural activity were
always having greater impact than manure
having impact in in the sols so in here
we can see B density was much higher in
in in Nal system again uh I only showing
the surface depth but we have this all
the way down to the 40 50 CMS which is
around 16 18 inches I I believe so
you're welcome to ask more detail if you
are focus on the deeper Soul profile so
when we look into aggregation again
tillage is making the huge difference
especially in the bigger Aggregates so
is effect of the disturbance on bigger
Aggregates is great and even but we can
also still see some of the significant
differences for menure Edition and which
is the orange here is has manure and
blue doesn't have manure you can see
some shift in the big one too in in
different sizes so when we move from the
planting for example this one was before
planting to the harvesting the responses
are changing under manure and and no
manure but when you go in the smaller
Aggregates those response kind of
constant between the different timing
but effect of manure is there same thing
in the noil has has an impact but
tillage impact is much greater than
adding manure in in the system because
it's kind of disturbing so here x access
we are going from planting to harvesting
from left to right and here on on on the
y axis we have soil micropores so you
you can just kind of this is the
convention till no manure you can kind
of see here from the planting to the
harvesting this is the year one and this
is the year two and you can see a
decrease from the mcro P so we have a
quite a significant effect on Agri paral
disturbance on the on the micropores
presence in the soils or proportion in
the soils we have a very clear impact of
harvesting that is decreasing the
micropores proportion we also have a
very clear impact of the tillage on them
and when we look at the scenario with
the manure we still have those effect in
conventional till systems but when we
look into no till system we see an
increase so the agricultural disturbance
is not as intense as in conventional
Tails so we start seeing the positive
effect effect of that in in in this
study so again effect of the manure is
still limited but in in in tillage or
disturbance effect is is more clear and
you can see that from the starting
points that there's a significant
difference and ending points there are
much different so the the effect of
activity in in field is is quite
significant but when we look into
microor we don't see that even though
they starting the same level and changes
in the micropores
proportion doesn't change too much so it
shows that disturbance is more effective
on the on the on the bigger pores in in
in the system and this also shows in
water release so when we look into more
into smaller ports or moisture content
in different pores there we can see a
significant impact of the manure so
especially in the noil systems dark blue
is representing solid manure and lighter
blue is no manure you can see there's a
significant effect even in in in small
smaller pores compared to compared to
bigger pores uh but tillage effect is
still there it is still there same thing
with the carbon content we have seen
differences from 0 to 6 in no
differences 6 to 12 in we have increas
if we have an effect of tillage for
example no till no manure conventional
till no manure significantly different
but when we look into conventional till
systems even though tillage has effect
and manure also shows an effect on it so
manure has effect on organic carbon or
organic matter in in both studies we
have seen
this so looking into more stable organic
carbon or or or active organic carbon we
have found the relationship between the
active organic carbon and bigger
Aggregates which are being heavily
Disturbed compared to smaller ones and
we have seen more stable organic carbon
in smaller Aggregates I think that was
something really important to know that
so for the conclusion this is an inner
layer surface of the aggregate uh I
thought it's a good slid for conclusion
and we can see different port sizes here
with different shapes and with different
sizes and we sometimes have the port
there continuous we have so particles
around it with different colors and with
different elements in it so focus on
this rectangle because most of the data
I'm going to show is from here so when
you when you look into Elemental
distribution is you can see from the top
to bottom the the these are the most
representative elements here they they
are in this area and from top to bottom
the the proportion is decreasing and we
can even map them and we can look at
into different pores and different
elements and see which one is higher in
the system you can see like lighter
color means we have more of that you can
see Iron this this particle is in Iron
this particle is calcium and we have
calcium around here too I I I'm focusing
on calcium because we have seen a quite
a good correlation between calcium and
so structure stability and and aggregate
sizes in in the system so they they
definitely play a critical role and
menure has all these in it including so
organic matter carbon nitrogen different
elements and so just consider them when
you're applying manure and and in the
questions that what you are
expecting so I am a and an assistant
professor and so management extension
specialist I'm in North Car State
University and don't hesitate to reach
out if you have any questions
[Music]